There are various types of
ad formats that game and
app developers can put into their apps.
The first and
most familiar to people are banners.
And probably the newest that
you'll see used are video ads.
There's different reasons you
might want to choose each.
Of course,
it depends on the type of app,
but there are also some other factors.
What's the location of
most of your users?
Do you have an in game economy if you're
trying to offer rewarded, videos for
instance?
You have to take those into accounts.
Understanding the payouts is a really
important part of understanding your
game monetization strategy.
So ads pay according to
how the advertiser bids.
These completely range.
Understanding all of these
is important because
they're going to determine when
you're looking at your analytics.
Why you are or are not getting paid?
And then you can optimize the ads, so
that it's a greater likelihood
somebody's going to engage with them.
If it's a cost for per completed view
and your doing a rewarded video ad then
maybe you want to show your video ads
right at the point where somebody needs
whatever say your offering
them extra life in your game.
Well you want to show that video
ad right where somebody needs it.
So that they're more likely
to complete the view,
so you're more likely to get paid.
If you're say, monetizing from cost
per install ads then you probably
don't want to bombard your users with
interstitials pop up ads because
they're going to see them, accidentally
click on them and then never install.
The ad networks themselves are going to
be optimizing based on the performance
of the ads within your app or game.
So if they see something that looks odd
or has a really low conversion rate,
you're less likely to get ads served or
even high quality ads
served to your app or game.
So it's really important to keep
an eye on those analytics and
then work with whoever
the providers are,
to make sure that you're
delivering the right results.
Mainly when choosing an ad partner,
it's important to choose ones that
offer features that you're looking for.
These features might be cross promotion.
So if you want to have the ad network do
double duty for you so that you can also
do things like promote in game items or
perhaps promote your next title.
It's important to choose an ad network
that can satisfy those objectives.
Another feature that some ad networks
have that people like to choose from
are things like transparency.
Can I see all of the ads that have
been shown if I have a kid's game, for
instance?
I want to make sure that the ads that my
players are seeing are age appropriate.
If I have a really sophisticated
back end that I'm working with,
I might want to choose an ad network
that has APIs that I can work with.
Perhaps I want to choose an ad
network that functions well with
other elements within my game.
For instance, If I'm using something
like Unity to build my game,
a development platform then I want to
choose ad networks that have plugins.
If I'm using a mediator, I want to
choose ad networks that I can then
plug into that mediator and
that all work nicely together.